hey i'm madison mills schools are
reopening
across the country but each individual
state
district and institution seems to have a
different idea of
what reopening looks like so joining us
to talk about what a safe reopening
could look like is bloomberg's linda
poon
linda thank you so much for making the
time to chat with us this afternoon
thank you for having me so linda just to
start us off can you give me an
overview of where we're at with the
school reopening process and any
updates that you have on how it's going
so far
yeah so schools have a lot of schools
that started opening reopening
after labor day um many schools i know
uh
have started fully remote um so they're
not gonna risk
in person some schools will consider
a hybrid model so some
days remote some days um in person
they're
planning to split the students up so
how it's going that's um so
there has been uh unfortunately reports
of clusters of cases
in schools here in the u.s um they've
had to have
we've had to ask students to quarantine
they've had to ask staff to quarantine
they've even had to shut down certain
schools for a couple days
to disrespect so
it's it's a really trial and error
process at this point and student
schools are still trying to figure out
you know what works and what doesn't
so linda given that what is kind of the
best
reopening plan in your opinion
yeah so to say any of them is the best
is
a little bit uh hard to really pick one
because they're all flawed
that's the unfortunate truth um there's
a lot of trade-offs so
if you do a fully reopen one
model then yes you're giving students
the developmental
uh education that they need but you're
putting them at risk
of covid um if you do a fully remote
then you have
a uh you know a problem with internet
access
lower income students and students in
rural areas don't necessarily have that
and then the hybrid is theoretically
supposed to be the best of both worlds
right you have some days
you still have students getting
interaction with peers with teachers
getting absorbed the face-to-face
interactions they need
especially younger students but the
problem with that
is you know you still have to figure out
how to get students
in school safely even if it's a smaller
size
um you still have to spend money that a
lot of school
districts may not have because um city
budgets have been sort of slashed
because of covid
and then you still have to figure out
the internet question um
so it's it's sure you have the best of
both worlds but you also have the
problems of both models
right and before we went live you and i
were talking about this idea of the
homework gap which i i hadn't heard that
phrase before can you talk about uh what
schools are doing to
address that and what that is yeah so
the homework app is why i just mentioned
this idea that not every kid have
internet access or not every kid has
access to a computer device
so we saw that being a huge problem with
schools initially shut down at the
beginning of pandemic and
schools were you know scrambling to make
everything fully remote
they were finding you know low-income
students
uh were scrambling to get internet
access
um and even though some cable companies
um
sort of stepped in and you know either
provided
low lower cost internet or free internet
they weren't always high quality
you had school scrambling to get digital
devices for kids um
new york city was trying to order ipads
for students um and they're trying to do
a lot of that stuff
right now but the problem is um
there's one there's a data gap so you
don't know which students for sure
don't have internet and then a lot of
the devices that they've been ordering
the past month are on back order so
students still don't
have the uh the equipment they need
and what that hap when that happens that
you have some students you just can't
log on
when you have those remote days and the
concern with that is that the students
who
already are you know don't have the
resources they're going to fall even
further behind than they
already um have fallen so therefore
you're sort of widing this gap
right and you mentioned that schools
don't necessarily
have the budgets that they had before
the pandemic
to address that homework gap and do
things like provide equipment
um i'm just curious have you seen any
unique
solutions that schools or districts are
implementing to
try and address this is there anything
you're seeing that's particularly
interesting to you as a solution to that
gap
um so there are some where they're
partnering with sort of community
centers and libraries to open up
the wi-fi hotspots either in parking
lots
um or they're rolling out these mobile
hotspots or putting wi-fi onto buses
and going to a park and having students
sit out there so there are some of these
um you know ideas that are like have
been rolled out
um i think one of the big problems with
scaling these
is that um
you know schools don't have the budget
right um
it takes money to put wi-fi's onto buses
um and with sort of making the school
building itself safe that takes a lot of
money too
so you have one estimate that i reported
on it'll take
an average size school district at least
1.8 million dollars to
not only get the ppes but to hire the
nurses and janitorial staff
in order to make schools safe and they
need to think about you know aging
schools
school buildings have ventilation
problems that they're gonna have to
solve that's gonna put
you know even more money so um you know
schools need federal funding um
but that's not so far not coming through
so you mentioned this large financial
cost for
schools that are choosing to reopen uh
but earlier you talked about this idea
of a hybrid model where
students go in some days and work from
or work from home learn from home
other days can you talk a bit about what
that hybrid model
might look like and how it could impact
both students and parents
yeah so what they what some schools are
suggesting
is somehow divide but divide the pop the
kids the student population
so some of them are ideas that i came
across
involved you know students with last
names from
a to l will go on tuesdays and thursdays
and then the rest of students will go
mondays and wednesday and now leave
friday for
disinfecting there are some ideas where
you know only elementary school students
will
go into in-person learning and that way
they can utilize the high schools and
the middle schools
and really social distance um
so and then there are other schools that
are sort of giving parents a choice
do you want to send your students to
school
um and you know for what classes so
these are ideas that haven't laid out
whether they work is still sort of up in
the air and
there is of course a huge logistical
problem with that because
you know if you're having schools and
our students come in on different days
i'm going to coordinate the buses while
also social distancing within the buses
so transportation is a huge coordination
problem
and as goes back to this idea there's
not enough funding there are
schools already spend 22 billion dollars
on
school transportation but now you need
more buses
you need a different arrangement and
then
some are on remote days you have parents
you have to figure out you know
how daycare is going to work you know
not all parents work
from home and they're not all parents
have that flexible schedules
and then so the good thing about
sort of the thing that part part of what
the hybrid model was also trying to
solve was this idea that students do
need to come in
for for behavioral services health
services
um and you know reduced lunch so
the idea is that at least they can get
some of that if they come in
um and then they can some students are
implementing sort of
meditation blocks right so
at least come in and get some of that um
you know stress release like a lot of
students are very traumatized
by all this so you know any sort of
engagement
is a good thing when it comes to
childhood development
and linda you mentioned some of the
services that schools provide we did get
an audience question in from a user who
wants to know
what are schools doing about children
who need free lunches
yeah so one thing the one thing is i
mentioned is the hybrid model so at
least when they come in they'll get
school lunches
um some of them have been doing what
they did
throughout the pandemic before it's you
know summer vacation happened which is
sort of send out the school lunches
um so it's something that
schools are still trying to figure out
um
and whether that's partnering with other
community centers
to send out school lunches or having
students come in
in some ways that's that's something
that the schools are sort of
figuring out on their own maybe with
their local government support
but when it comes to sort of a national
strategy um there is one
and another audience question we have is
do workplaces have to change with
working parents and school situations uh
and that's a little bit off
a course from what you've reported on
linda but i'm curious if you've heard
anything interesting about
workplaces that are shifting to
accommodate for
uh school now that were in september
certainly i think some workplaces might
have better um
you know parental leave policies
um but i think the one thing that's
really
um a challenge is for lower income
families right
essential workers who you know work in
grocery stores who work in restaurants
who don't have that flexible schedule
and we can expect every employer to
decide on its own that
they want to help their employees
so sure it would be great if you know
offices also
figure out you know a way to accommodate
but that's sort of
um in my view at least is unrealistic um
and it you know it's
it's not something that um you know
really is on the workplaces to figure
out um it's something that you know
communities have to come together uh
governments have to come together to
figure out to have
works employers individually
you know grant some sort of relief in
some ways is
it's really hard to expect to do that
and you mentioned earlier this idea that
some schools are allowing parents to
kind of
have a say in the matter and make make
their own choices about what their
child's education might look like
i'm curious do we have any initial data
on
how parents feel about back to school
overwhelmingly right do we know if
parents are eager to get their kids back
in the classroom or if they're opting to
do more homeschooling and things like
that
um so in terms of hard data i don't have
that but
i have her antidotes where you know
students are
just as worried about sending their kids
back to school
as you know teachers are about
getting kids back to school um so
there have been a lot of students who
just opt for um
you know fully remote i did talk to one
parent who
um you know he wants his students his
kids to be safe
but he understands that math is a
particularly hard subject so
in theory he would like his kids go
into school and you know get that
engagement
um but you know when it comes to health
versus
your childhood sort of educational
development it's a really hard thing for
parents to balance
um so it's a it's a tough call
um and and um it's hard for students to
say
you know i want my students back in
school
but also i want them to be safe and you
know
the family members are the ones who who
are sort of um
sort of most threatened right so
students as we know
sort of the uh the data on whether
how sick kids get um so
far kids don't get super sick um
but whether they can transmit it to a
grandparent who
they're living with with them um is a
huge concern
for parents uh if i had to go into
school
just for math i would be very unhappy
child
topic that would be the worst school day
ever for me yeah that's not my favorite
subject as a
journalist i'm wondering we've talked
about parents and we've talked about
students but what about the teachers
themselves what
what's their biggest concern right and
um
how are local officials assuaging those
fears
um so teachers are
terrified rightly so um you have one
third
of public and private school teachers in
the u.s
over the age of 50. so they are much
more susceptible
um to getting incredibly sick from
cover 19. um we've heard stories about
students retire sorry
teachers retiring instead of risking
their lives
and this all comes amid you know an
ongoing teacher shortage in the country
um so teachers also need sort of the
mental support that a lot of experts are
recommending for students
um and
um they're also trying to learn
how to navigate this new format right so
a lot of
schools are doing remote learning that's
not something that teachers have been
trained in
um so we seen the big sort of
piloting with remote learning in the
first um
at the beginning of the pandemic and a
lot of teachers you know it was hard to
engage the students
um they were trying to figure out you
know is it best just to have students
watch
you know a video versus live live
learning um and whether
um there's their school they're
requiring that teachers do some form of
live learning
um and then the other thing that i read
about that
um i mentioned earlier is that
you know teachers themselves are digging
into their own pockets
to provide the resources for remote
learning to um if there's
sort of any in person to sort of um
you know ready the classrooms uh i think
one statistic i read is that teachers
some teachers are spending over a
thousand dollars of their own pockets
just to
you know get their classroom to be safe
and another audience question we're
getting in on this topic linda
is um what power do teachers unions have
to protect
themselves and and to support their
fellow co-workers during this time
yeah so um what i've read and what i've
seen
is that teachers union have been uh you
know
threatening strikes um to try to get
you know local officials and
administrators to sort of
um has some protections right so in new
york city
uh schools have been delayed because um
teachers threaten strike because
the buildings just aren't they don't
feel the buildings are safe
um so that's something that near city is
going on right now
um in la i remember reading that
they were trying the teachers union were
trying to come to some form of agreement
about what sort of education is should
teachers be required
to provide um it's the whole thing i
mentioned
whether it's live learning versus you
know putting on some sort of video
um so you know teachers you can have
sort of
side um to to
sort of pressure uh local administrators
to sort of you know get get the teachers
um
opinions in there right and linda you
you
mentioned earlier um the idea of doing
some outdoor learning
i'm curious you know we are seeing of
course wildfires
uh taking over the west and hurricanes
and things like that
what will happen throughout the school
year as the seasons change and we have
these
natural disasters how could outdoor
learning work
long term um that's a very good question
and i think that's something that's cool
are
you know very um aware that they need to
sell i
i don't think there's too many um
schools that are
really looking at all outdoor classrooms
um because even without all these
horrible weather events you still have
rain and snow
and you know you know there are still
very warm temperatures you can't keep
kids outside for
six hours straight right with extreme
heat in some parts of the city
so as far as how if that can be a
long-term solution
um it doesn't seem like it's
um the best solution i mean there are
certain
pluses uh but once
you know these wire wire fires and and
whatnot
kind of you know really starting well
they already are right
um so whether that's a long cut solution
is
probably not and linda you've also done
some reporting on
college campuses and how they're
handling the covet 19 pandemic
do you have any different advice you
would give to
college administrators about how to
avoid uh
having outbreaks on their campuses
in terms of advice um i think it's it's
colleges have a
like in some ways colleges do have a
little bit harder right so because you
have students
living on campus um the ones that do
reopen campus
um so you have issues with um you know
parties are one thing that's been um
sort of creating sort of covet clusters
but
you have to understand that you know
mingling with other kids with other
students
is part very much part of the college
experience so to expect students not to
do that
um and to put the sort of emphasis on
them the responsibility on them to do it
is uh you know it's it hasn't worked
we've seen many campuses have sort of
coveted case
outbreaks and had to either shut down
the campuses or switch forward to remote
we've heard some campuses are trying to
send students
back which you know is another issue
that they're going to have to figure out
because
it's not just you know students from the
local community
students from different states so if you
have a cluster and you're sending
students back
your your risks you risk spreading
covert even further right
um and then there's housing situations
um i've
i've read students are aren't able to
get out of certain housing agreements
that they sign long before covet
and when schools shut down there are
some students
in other cases some students don't know
where to go because
it's not like for many if not you can
just
buy a plane ticket and go home right so
um
those are just stuff that colleges um
have to be extra sort of aware of and
not expect students to try to figure out
what they should do if there are cluster
cases on campus
well linda we can't thank you enough for
making the time to join us this
afternoon and talk about your reporting
uh for those of you watching please
follow bloomberg quick take wherever you
get your news we're on facebook
instagram twitter and youtube
and again thank you so much for making
the time for us today
thank you